[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the capcom
showcase where we'll share exciting new
updates on our upcoming games
we have some surprises in store and hope
you enjoy the show
let's begin
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm ryozo tsujimoto producer of the
monster hunter series thank you for
tuning in to today's capcom showcase
we're excited to bring you the latest
info on monster hunter rise sun break
which will finally be released at the
end of this month
to kick things off we've got a brand new
trailer to show you
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be careful
wow let's go for a ride
you look like you still got that fire
inside yo gal yes you do as well good
elton what do you say full steam ahead
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
first let me introduce a returning
locale
the jungle area that debuted in the
second generation of monster hunter
games is back in sun break
you'll notice that the jungle's
appearance changes over time it's a
nostalgic area that both veteran hunters
and new players are sure to enjoy and of
course we've updated the jungle with new
elements and endemic life specifically
for its return in sun break long time
fans can look forward to exploring the
devastated ruins around the coastal area
from the monster hunter frontier series
comes espinas
espinas means thorns in spanish as the
name implies thorny scales cover its
body
normally espionage enjoys a quiet life
and sleeps peacefully but when it senses
danger nearby it explodes into a violent
rampage even though it can seem docile
espionage has a two-faced nature that
can be extremely dangerous
the flagship monster of monster hunter 4
gore magala is
back gore magala is a sightless creature
with black scales and sensitive wing
membranes used to sense the presence of
prey
[Music]
as gore magala's sensing ability
increases its two horns change form and
it enters the frenzy state
while in a frenzy state it gets so
powerful that the ground beneath begins
to break
and it uses its huge claws as an anchor
during powerful attacks
[Music]
in addition the trailer also shows the
daimyo hermitage and the pyro rock
nakadaki subspecies which adds explosive
elements makes its fiery debut there are
still more monsters that have yet to be
revealed so stay tuned for more sun
break announcements in the future
there's one more thing i want to share
with you all so please watch the
following video
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
a free demo for monster hunter rise sun
break is coming to both nintendo switch
and steam the demo will be available to
download as shown
in the jungle locale introduced today
you'll be able to take on astalos
the new switch skill swap system as well
as new silk bind attacks will be
available for play
we'll have a few tutorial quests
available for new players that will
teach you the basic mechanics and moves
after mastering the basics you'll be
ready to take on other monsters in the
demo to test your skills for veteran
hunters an advanced quest will also be
available where you can take on an extra
challenging version of sunbreak's
flagship monster malzeno
the demo supports multiplayer for up to
four players and there's no limit to the
number of times you can attempt quests
get an early taste of sun break action
with this free demo you can download it
from the nintendo eshop and steam store
page
also we would like for you to keep two
things in mind when purchasing monster
hunter rise sunbreak
so you will be able to enjoy all the
added contents
[Music]
following sun breaks release we plan to
release a number of free title updates
please enjoy this quick video preview of
what's on the way
[Applause]
our first title update scheduled for
august 2022
will add lucent nargakuka
this monster will be a part of the first
free title update to come to sunbreak
post launch
in addition to the lucent nagakuga we're
also adding a new area the iconic
forlorn arena with future title updates
we plan on including additional monsters
variants and more
our title update release schedule is as
follows the second title update is
planned for a fall 2022 release the
third title update will come in winter
2022
and there's more to come in 2023
each title update will include
additional monsters and other elements
we hope you'll check them out
[Music]
monster hunter rise sun break will be
released worldwide on june 30th 2022
[Music]
digital pre-orders for sun break are now
available on both nintendo switch and
steam
pre-orders will also receive a special
bonus palamute and palico layered armor
set
we're planning on keeping you updated
with more information soon
please visit the official website and
follow monster hunter social channels
for more info
that wraps up our news for monster
hunter rise sun break
thanks for tuning in and enjoy the rest
of the capcom showcase
now we will present the capcom spotlight
corner
street fighter 6
coming soon
the next generation of street fighter is
currently in development and has
something fun for everyone to enjoy fan
favorites ryu and chun li will be
heating up the battle stage right
alongside some of the newest fighters
luke and jamie
with breathtaking new visuals
unleash unprecedented battles with the
all-new battle system
street fighter 6 reimagines the fighting
game experience with new modes that will
allow you to experience the street
fighter universe
what awaits you in this game look
forward to our next announcement later
this year
celebrating the 35th anniversary of the
street fighter franchise the capcom
fighting collection will be released
later this month
included is the first ever release of
red earth outside of arcades hyper
street fighter 2
five dark stalkers titles and more
ten of the best fighting games from the
arcade era are included in one package
all of the titles included will be
playable online
so play a match against your friends
or fight online against new challengers
enjoy a full range of online matches
capcom fighting collection will launch
on june 24th 2022
pre-orders are available now please
visit the official website for more
information
play the games you loved again
capcom arcade stadium has expanded
capcom arcade second stadium coming july
22nd 2022
saturday night slam masters
magic sword
black tiger
eco fighters and more combined for a
total of 32 arcade titles in addition to
a bundle that features all 32 titles
each title is available for individual
purchase and features
with lots of quality of life options
all players will receive sun sun for
free when downloading the base game
the bundle featuring all 32 titles is
available for pre-order now get display
frame set 1 as a bonus for pre-ordering
to celebrate get the capcom arcade
stadium title
street fighter 2 the world warrior
free for a limited time
we hope you try out the capcom arcade
stadium as well
[Music]
next up is an update on capcom's new
team based action game
exoprimal
hi everyone i'm takuro hiraoka director
of exoprimal
we have a new trailer to show today
that includes lots of gameplay
let's take a look
i am the artificial intelligence
leviathan
your personnel data indicates you are a
suitable specimen to join an ongoing
experiment
under my supervision ibs corp conducts
its most important research here
welcome to bikitowa island
you have been selected for a live combat
test
the first team to complete their
assignment wins
my archives encompass exhaustive records
of human history
these animals are riddled with errors
and institutional bias your species is
susceptible to mass delusion
fascinating
humans dread the other
you seek to evolve yet you do not want
to change you tear down curtains yet
fear revelations
even when what is revealed is of your
own creation
combat data is required to develop the
exosuit at ibs we're always reaching for
better
always
humanity resists quantification
an interesting variable within your
behavior lies the answer what is
variable
shall become fixed
humans
fight
and die for me
carnage module online
[Music]
i call your attention to the unstoppable
raptor board
calculating chance of employee retention
chance calculated at 8.7 percent
you must fight harder than ever if you
wish to survive
a more grueling combat experiment is
called for
you will now witness a small fragment of
the war game
you need to keep fighting till we can
figure out how to destroy
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed the trailer
now i will get into more detail about
the game
developed by ibs corporation leviathan
is a next-gen ai that guides players
throughout exoprimal via voice
navigation and augmented reality
displays
leviathan appears before players as a
massive human-like figure or as a
surveillance drone called a watcher
the trailer shows leviathan unleashing
hordes of dinosaurs
players will battle these dinosaurs
after being forced into leviathan's
infinitely repeating war games why is
leviathan bringing dinosaurs into our
world and why is leviathan repeating
these war games
solve the mystery by playing the main
game mode
dino survival
let me provide a brief gameplay
introduction
exo primal is a team-based action game
in dino survival two squads of five race
to complete objectives
teams must follow leviathan's directives
and complete the mission before their
rivals to win
these directives will feature a dynamic
mix of missions in fact we just saw some
in the latest trailer
there's dinosaur call where teams must
eliminate a specific dinosaur in vetol
defense teams protect a grounded
aircraft from dinosaur onslaughts
in data key security teams escort a
valuable asset to its destination
destroy targets and omega charge with
the powerful omega hammer
an energy taker teams compete to collect
the most energy
you also saw a glimpse of a strange and
terrifying creature known as a
neo-tyrannosaurus
while there are situations where you
directly engage enemy players
there are other times where you band
together with rivals to take down a
major foe this variety of missions will
keep players on their toes in dino
survival the missions change based on
players progression through the game the
experience will be different every time
you play even in matches with familiar
surroundings and objectives
by playing dino survival you will unlock
story sequences
and also earn rewards such as experience
points to increase your player and exo
suit levels
we'll provide more details about this
at a later date
now that we've detailed dino survival
let's move on to exo suits
we showed two new exosuits today
garage is an assault roll exo suit
it uses explosives to set areas of blaze
and bombards enemies with ricochet
grenades
vigilant is also an assault rolex's suit
it wields a destructive railgun to snipe
from long range
we have even more exo suits to share
with you in the future so look forward
to upcoming announcements
we have one last announcement for today
welcome
to my research facility
we're conducting a closed network test
for exoprimal
players will be able to try the game
ahead of release
help us test the game's online
infrastructure
and make improvements ahead of launch
sign up to participate today
the closed network test will allow you
to experience dino survival before the
game's launch next year we look forward
to having you join in
that's all for today
we plan to release exoprimal in 2023
until then
keep an eye on our website and social
media
thank you for watching
next we have a message about dragon's
dogma which recently celebrated its 10th
anniversary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm hideaki atsuno game
director at capcom a few weeks ago we
celebrated the 10th anniversary of
dragon's dogma
thanks to all of you for joining us in
this
celebration the world of dragon's dogma
has since spread to various different
kinds of media
ranging from games such as dragons dogma
and the dark arisen expansion
to digital comics and a netflix original
animated series
in the coming days we will be releasing
a video celebrating 10 years of dragon's
dog
talking about how
and what dragon's dogma came to be
so whether you're a long time fan or
just curious about the series we'll have
something for you to enjoy
we hope you
check it out
once again thank you all
so much
and now we have a bunch of updates from
the resident evil franchise
hello everyone i'm tsuyoshi konda the
producer of resident evil village thanks
to all of our fans village has sold over
6 million units worldwide
everyone on the team is incredibly happy
to see so many people enjoy the game
thank you for your support
the resident evil series continues to
bring fun experiences to people around
the world
we want long time fans and people who
are new to resident evil to enjoy this
storied franchise
let's start with this video
[Music]
it's all right
it's all right
i can show you things even chris doesn't
know what i can do
i want to live a normal life
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
what's going on
you look just like me
oh now we have a new little rabbit
it's time
marking the target
it's showtime
now
what next
[Applause]
sorry to keep you waiting
we're happy to reveal the dlc for
resident evil village we promised last
year
we think this new experience will be
worth the wait
this dlc includes three major features
first the third person
many people asked for this and we were
able to add it into the game now you'll
be able to see ethan as he desperately
fights for survival players that have
already experienced ethan's journey can
enjoy the new perspective and animations
too
the mercenaries returns with additional
orders in an arcade style action game
where focus has been put on the
exhilarating feeling of defeating
relentless hordes of enemies new stages
are included as well as additional
playable characters such as chris
redfield and heisenberg of course lady
dimitresk will be there too
we've really fueled this mode up
enjoy looking down on your foes from
over nine feet above as lady dimitress
slashes her enemies aside
the third edition is one you've surely
been waiting for an additional story
shadows of rose today let me introduce
just a bit of this story
rose the beloved daughter of the main
protagonist ethan is now a grown-up main
character in this new story mode in this
sequel to the main story of village you
can experience rose's struggles with the
terrifying power she was born with to
break free of the curse of her powers
she enters the consciousness of the mega
my seat
there she meets a girl who looks just
like her
in this mysterious realm of
consciousness time and space is warped
beyond recognition
rose is guided by a being who calls
himself michael who might be of
assistance with removing her powers
shadows of rose is set completely in a
third person perspective in the realm of
consciousness you won't only face
creatures but the world itself seems to
be attacking you
enjoy the horror of the world itself
being your greatest enemy
how will rose find freedom from her
mysterious powers
the dlc for resident evil village
winters expansion includes all three of
these major additions
in addition resident evil village gold
edition a bundle of winter's expansion
with the face game will be released
simultaneously the release date is
planned for october 28 2022.
resident evil reverse will also be in
service on the same date october 28 2022
we hope that you are looking forward to
it
how did you like that
also as already announced we are working
on making the main story of village
available on mac so that even more
people can enjoy resident evil
in addition the main story of village is
planned to be playable on playstation
vr2
we're working hard on bringing you the
ultimate immersive experience worthy of
next-gen in resident evil village
so look forward to future announcements
up next a game that was announced
just a few days ago
[Music]
located baby eagles
i guess you me
picked the wrong spot to vacation eh
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins
now
if i could just forget what happened
that night
the pain
even for a second
this time
it can be different
it has to
hi everyone i'm yasujiro
director of resident evil 4
and i'm yoshiaki hirabayashi producer of
resident evil 4
this title is a reimagining of resident
evil 4 based on the original 2005
release
similar to other titles in the series we
are carefully preserving what makes the
original title special while updating it
with modern flourishes for everyone to
enjoy when it launches in 2023
today we'll reintroduce a bit of the
game's story
resident evil 4 is set six years after
the events in raccoon city depicted in
resident evil 2 and resident evil 3. the
main character of the game leon s
kennedy survived the raccoon city
incident and was assigned as an agent
directly under the president of the
united states leon is dispatched to a
quiet village in europe as part of a
mission to rescue the kidnapped daughter
of the president
you might notice leon is much more
mature and fearless due to his past
experiences
the main enemies of this game wait for
him
the experience of being attacked by
hordes of crazed gennado is truly an
iconic moment from resident evil
in order to truly bring out the concept
of terror of people controlled by
madness the gonado have been completely
redesigned
let's take a closer look
at the game itself
the over-the-shoulder camera returns of
course
leon arrives at a dense and dangerous
forest
we want to nail the feeling of
loneliness and fear of not knowing what
lies ahead even more so than the
original
of course
there will also be thrilling battles
people that played the recent resident
evil 2 and resident evil 3 should find
this familiar
look forward to future announcements
where we'll have more information on the
game
resident evil 4 is being developed for
playstation 5 xbox series x series s and
pc
the release date will be march 24th 2023
we are aiming to create a resident evil
4 that everyone can enjoy so please look
forward to it
thank you
thank you so much
what did you think about the latest
information on resident evil village and
resident evil 4
both games are currently in development
for those that can't wait for the
release check out the following
games oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time
[Music]
resident evil 7 which brought the series
back to its survival horror roots
and the reimagining of classic titles
resident evil 2
and resident evil 3.
these three titles built with re engine
return with current gen features
including support for 4k
high frame rate and ray tracing
as well as 3d audio for an even more
immersive experience
these titles are available for
playstation 5 and xbox series x and
series s beginning today
in addition playstation 4 and xbox one
players can enjoy a free digital upgrade
to current gen via the digital upgrade
program and smart delivery
for pc users an update patch will be
available on the same date
for newcomers and veterans of survival
horror alike we hope you enjoyed the
immersion these new versions offer
welcome to the family
that's all for today's announcements
thank you
that wraps up today's show we hope
you're as excited as we are about some
of our upcoming games thank you to
everyone new and old fans alike for
tuning in
we look forward to sharing more updates
with you soon
[Music]